[Music]
we're going to buy bicycles
we're just shopping left and
right i feel so bad
because i decided to not go for the line
cruiser the
hachima
i really wanted that car but
i'm not used to driving in tokyo yet and
i just kind of feel like getting that
big of a vehicle as an everyday car
it doesn't really make sense until i'm
more used to driving here i think
so to feel better we buy bicycles
we're going to bike instead everywhere
you get a bicycle
you get a bicycle
we're going to bank
it's been so hot the street is so cool
it's finally cooled down a bit it feels
so much nicer outside
a lot of shopping streets have
speakers
i don't know if you can hear it but
they're playing music
i just it just stopped
listening
copyright you having fun everyone's
having fun
except me
i found one i really like
and i think marcy as well
they look amazing we got a bike
both of us
uh they're so cool so we have to wait 30
minutes and they're gonna prepare them
feels a bit like being at disneyland
with the music playing
this is huge
i can't even see that far
it's like an indoor outdoor mall i've
seen a couple of these
[Music]
what's that funny store she likes this
is huge
this is a tight fit
i could fit one
but not two how's it going at the front
is it tight
[Music]
picked up the other car
car why do i keep calling a car it's
this third time that shop owner shop uh
clerk whatever and he was so nice he
helped us get the bike in the car and he
followed us to our parking
because he was like not sure if we knew
what we were doing
or if we needed to help which we
definitely did
but yeah they're great really good ones
yeah i'm happy with that
first class huh
you're looking extra moth at the minute
maya you blend in really well
[Music]
we're in uh ebisu for some food take two
on the bank today we're gonna try it
again i also got a gimbal now we can get
some cool arty shot
some b-roll as they call it
it's at 50-50 chance of rain your hair
looks amazing girl
i feel like those annoying tourists with
this thing but it's all for their steady
camera footage
where does it go
miners is in charge of navigation today
so i just get to tag along
said 50 50 chance of rain today
what do you guys reckon
is that a train or thunder
that's scary we're gonna die where's it
i'm leaving you
well damn it rain
there was a 50 50 chance
and we lost oh gosh i was like 50
percent chance that's no way oh i just
missed a thumb there
take me back to the station
50
chance huh
50
we're going to the bank now
looking like we just went for a swim
oh
[Music]
what do you think our chances for
getting the bank account set up today is
50 50
70
i like those
all right let's do this
[Music]
we did it we have a japanese bank
account they were great super helpful
now that we have all the papers it was
really easy actually it feels really
good to get that done that's a big step
did you have any issues
vending machine
tofu and dumpling gyoza
where are you taking us marzia
a bonsai shop
actually did you know bonsai it's just
the way you treat the tree it's not
necessarily what the tree is called
we're getting all kinds of weather today
[Music]
i like this one
[Music]
we both got a tree he said it was easy
to take care of i'm
getting used out of my little bit of
japanese that i get which feels really
good we're gonna head back down
[Music]
that's so pretty
he said it was easy
you grab
the long pieces and you just
take them off he also gave us um
english instructions so
so pretty though god damn this one i got
today
it's looking good on the shelf very cute
i'm working out
very epic
good day edgar
we've all had those days huh
[Music]
i don't have the weights for you like
i'll get an olympic bar right there
but
i can actually do exercises with my own
body here
i just saw my speaker there
i had to move it over here today
it weighs 60 kilos
it was a nightmare and i never want to
do that again but yeah it's coming along
clean i want to do a setup tour so yeah
let me know if you want a setup tour and
i'll make it
once i've dealt with the cables dude
this room is so aesthetic it's like a
man cave but epic all right so this is
the sponsored segment why yet again the
ridge wallet
i love using this thing ever since my
last promo in japan there's just an
abundance of cards like for the train
obviously my bank cards i can't show
this but my card document for my vet
yadda yadda there's a lot of cards okay
this is a my typical wallet size
boom the ridge baby this won't fit 12
cards but this will so there you go it
even fits cash and the back this has
become a great tool for keeping all my
extra cards there's just so many it
actually works out perfectly they have a
ton of cool different designs i'm using
a different one this time around very
nice uh check them out on the website
it's a highly rated product over 50 000
five-star reviews
they offer a lifetime warranty and you
are allowed to try it for 45 days and
then see if you want to keep it or not
won't be disappointed it's a great
wallet and also a great gift for
father's day if you check out the link
in description enter code pewdiepie you
get 15 off so definitely take advantage
of that offer if you end up picking up
one and support the channel and the
vlogs i appreciate it and uh rich for
being a great sponsor and great product
so thank you
are we having a good time out here
it works do you want to try it
kill it girl
that is so satisfying
like brand new
it's just like the video game
i'm out of breath because
i was working out but marcia's
oh god
i went to check marce's balcony it looks
so nice i went to pick up and i saw this
little cutie
going for a little drink huh
there's water in the cracks
just chilling
ah
he's fine okay
hello
this is the
origin story
when i become plant man
one day he gets bitten
by a radioactive japanese oh i can feel
his wetness i haven't seen an insect
like this
in a very long time i gotta show mercy
what's it i found a friend on your
balcony it's not a spider don't worry
isn't cool
all right
you get to live in our garden how's that
off you go okay
we are friends for life apparently
he's so cute
bro
are you gonna be okay
oh he's fine
okay
all right
bye bye
[Music]
going to collect our ankle it's the day
and then we're going to the town hall
right after to register them you have to
do that and then i'm actually meeting up
with the
representative for the car purchase and
they're going to help me with the
process hopefully this goes well i'm
cautiously optimistic look at that i got
my little frog too
nice
[Music]
this is really cute can't wait someone
took my spot
excuse me oh he was so sweet
i gotta show you how he whoa what a cool
car
so
here's mine he forgot the g but i didn't
have the heart to tell him it doesn't
matter because i don't have time to
change anyway it looks good first so
from now on i'm shelbur and
[Music]
mazia
like there you see that line you twist
it like
and this sticker marks up so what you do
is you grab it
and he showed you grab it like
it's hard to do with one hand but like
that and then you one two three four
five you press down
try and keep down and steady
for like a couple of seconds and that's
it
ah already failed he gave me an applause
because i did it right on the first try
why it's so hard when it's not flat
we'll have to master this
we got to go to the town home right away
so you register these at the town hall
and i need it to buy
my car basically some people say they
have oh by the way he gave us
it was so sweet he gave me present
present
it's a refill i think
and then he said when we left he said
please enjoy your life in japan and i
was like
i'm back at the town hall
to register the uncle i have to request
a document as well
i'm not sure which one though so i'm a
bit nervous i don't know how to do this
a lot a lot of fails lately we failed
again
you're not allowed to
have symbols
or like i you know i had the wavy
pattern on mine huncle
you're not allowed to have that at least
if you register it at a town hall i'm
sure i can use it for like
daily signatures maybe i don't know i'll
have to look that up it's just kind of
weird huh
i had no idea i do have another one
so
i'm going back to collect that one and
register that one instead it just wasn't
as cool but i guess i'll have to live
without having a cool hunker
busy day
look they have these at 7 11.
thank you
i'm only only nice because i'm filming
on busy days
rice ball saves the day okay i found
that
i feel kind of dumb i'm not gonna lie
for thinking i just want a cool one at
the government place they didn't say
mine was very cool kakui so
i'm going to register our hanko now
and hopefully they'll accept this one i
think the default here has become to
assume things are not gonna go well that
way when they do go well it's like yes
we did it i love using the vice it's
awesome
[Music]
we went to the wrong office
today's is the whole
mixed bag of everything going wrong but
you know what it was so fun riding the
bike that it doesn't even matter i don't
mind riding bike again
such an aesthetic looking shot
the pink and the blue
and the marching move
these bikes
amazing i love that such a good purchase
success
we did it
the car is registered
i have a bunch of papers i have no idea
what they mean
and i got pretty good at stamping
you saw it the rest of the day's free we
can do whatever
we can play around with our handcuffs
you know get some full use out of them
you live and you learn anyway we did it
so it doesn't matter
oops
we are going to park to have some lunch
a very very late lunch
it's so nice to ride the bike i love it
oh god
supermarket bento
we got
salmon
spaghetti
a meatball
i will break my pescetarianism i don't
know i just like the spaghetti rice and
salmon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is it shaky
these bikes are incredible
i love it you still pedal but just a bit
you know
ah
the japan line
weather is kind of [ __ ] but at least
it's cold nice and uh
nice temperature
good thing we have electric jesus oh
this is brutal
even with electric
back home that was a really nice day i
think that was my favorite day in uh
japan so far had so much fun and all we
did was go to different town halls
we went shopping as well i got a bit of
shopping dopamine i don't think i had
that in a very long time i was like
there's so much stuff here i love it i
have to buy all of it i bought three
items to me that's insane
yeah good day i also came back and had
some very exciting news about the car
situation that i'm super happy about so
stay tuned for that